bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches dans
les séries policières vous avez toujours
le bon flic et le méchant flic
cette fois ci dans ces caches vous aurez
deux méchants
bonjour aujourd'hui nous allons nous
demander comment va se terminer cette
crise bonjour estelle bonjour olivier
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ces caches
cela fait plus d'un an maintenant que le
coc vite 19 est apparu dans nos vies
crise sanitaire crise économique comment
tout cela va se terminer si on va en
parler à dans cette émission et pour
cela en deuxième partie nous serons en
liaison depuis les états unis la
caroline du nord plus précisément avec
max keiser ancien trader et animateur de
l'émission kaiser report sur rt
internationale l'arrivée du colis de 19
a ravagé un bon nombre d'économies
oblige les pays à mettre sur la table de
nombreux plans de relance mais tu as an
parfois les finances publiques à rude
épreuve
rien qu'en france la crise devrait
coûter 4 124 milliards d'euros d'euros
au pays entre 2020 2021 et 2022 à la clé
cette année un déficit public de 9 %
les détails avec le tiroir cash
d'antoine basse
[Musique]
quelle trace le coc vide les strates x
sur le long terme on s'avancerait un peu
trop en ayant une réponse formelle à
cette question si on commence à
apercevoir le bout du tunnel grâce à la
vaccination
il est évident que l'économie a pris un
sérieux coup dans les dents ni avril
persie a posé un chiffre sur cet état de
fait 4 124 milliards d'euros c'est ce
que coûterait cette crise à l'état
français sur trois ans entre 2020 et
un chiffre énorme et étonnamment précis
qui prend en compte les dépenses
engagées comme le chômage partiel le
fonds de solidarité de coûts des mesures
sanitaires ou les impôts qui ne sont pas
rentrées dans les caisses
à cause de la récession de 2020 de 8,2
pour cent
la france n'est pas la seule dans ce cas
en europe sauf que d'autres pays se sont
retrouvés plongés dans la crise avec des
déficits de départ beaucoup moins
important avant le vide la france avait
déjà une dette de 100 % du pib
quand l'allemagne n'était qu'à 60% par
exemple on n'était pas tous sur la même
ligne de départ et on ne sera donc pas
tous égaux pour remonter la pente
on pourra se consoler un petit peu en se
disant qu'il y a pire que nous si on
traverse l'atlantique le déficit
budgétaire américain n'est pas mal non
plus 4500 milliards de dollars sur deux
ans 600 milliards rien qu'en mars
dernier des chiffres si gros qu'il
laisse forcément imaginé un impact
durable sur le monde et son économie
olivier c'est vrai que quand on regarde
ces chiffres on peut parfois avoir le
sentiment que tout cela va mal finir
pour autant l'otc dea par exemple table
sur un rebond de l'économie mondiale de
5 6% est cette année et 4 % l'an
prochain alors cette crise va-t-elle
réellement laissé des traces sur le long
terme par exemple est ce que dans dix
ans on observera toujours les stigmates
de cette crise bien sûr bien sûr puisque
je vous ai distincts phase c'est un fan
modèles ont depuis 20 ans on fonctionne
sur la veille que ce soit la dette
publique mais la dette privée aussi aux
états unis pour les citer vous avez tout
marche avec de la dette la dette
étudiante
qui est sur des niveaux qu'on n'avait
jamais atteint la dette pour
l'automobile qui est sur des niveaux
jamais atteints la dette des cartes de
crédit parce que vous savez que les
américains ont cinq ou six cartes de
crédit sur lequel vous avez cinq ou six
découvert et donc vous avez une dette
qui est énorme et cette dette là il faut
pas croire
elle est à 0 % ou 0 % + cd cd taux de
2,2
d'intérêt qui sont entre 8 15 16 même
20% sur certains emprunts donc
évidemment ça coûte très cher tout ça et
il faudrait que il y ait des hausses de
revenus mais comme sous la présidence de
monsieur obama
il a complètement mis par terre la
classe moyenne américaine
ça va être compliqué de repartir donc
vous dis aujourd'hui vous avez de la
dette qui est mise vous avez de la
monnaie qui est émise
tout ça pour camoufler le le manque de
croissance et dans dix ans vous aurez
des chiffres qui vous montreront que la
reprise de croissance n'était pas là
qu'on a qu'on dit continuer à s'endetter
et que donc les monnaies seront par
terre alors peut-être avant dix ans même
et
et voilà donc non le la croissance
explosive en 2020 2021 enfin en 2021 en
qui rattraperait ou et qui ferait que
dans quelques années on s'aperçoit fut
petit qui a eu qui s'est passé quelque
chose en 2020 me paraît tout à fait trop
optimistes merci olivier tout de suite
la deuxième partie de cette émission
et cette semaine nous sommes en liaison
depuis à la caroline du nord aux états
unis avec max keiser ancien trader est
journaliste pour rt international
bonjour mac bienvenue dans ces caches
bonjour c'est un plaisir de vous voir un
plaisir d'être ici
un mec c'est la crise économique liée à
l'arrivée du cosy de 19
aura-t-elle raison de nos économies la
crise du coc vite fait partie d'une
crise aurait plus globale dans notre
économie qui a commencé en 2008 lorsque
le système mondial s'est arrêtée puis on
a tenté d'innover l'économie mondiale en
liquidités mais ça n'a pas fonctionné
nous avons toujours une économie
mondiale qui est en détresse et qui
s'amenuise
la politique des banques centrales ne
fonctionne pas donc la crise continue et
empire la crise du coc vide n'est qu'une
partie du beaucoup plus grande crise
libyenne réaction la copie dans une
crise plus large
on en a parlé maintes et maintes fois
ici
lalala covin n'est qu'un des étapes de
la dégradation de l'économie depuis 2008
en 2008 il ya une une fracture une
première fracture mais déjà on avait
commencé en 2000 en 2000 les banques
centrales avaient déjà mis de l'argent
sur la table beaucoup d'argent en 2008
elles ont réitéré
elle est là dans un ensemble parfait
puisque la banque du japon la bce
les américains et on a essayé de
camoufler chose on a essayé de de créer
une illusion de croissance avec cette
dette est illusion qui est tombé au
moment du coc vide puisque là c'était
encore plus compliqué parce qu'il en
fallait beaucoup beaucoup pour essayer
de maintenir les choses et et on vous
l'avait dit ici plusieurs fois le jour
où il y aura un pépin les banques
centrales ont dû au lean et elles ont
fait du all in et et elle continue et je
pense que c'est pas fini parce que
maintenant elles ont mis le doigt dans
le pot de confiture et que vous leur
tirez pas facilement et donc on est
parti pour probablement une phase 2 de
création monétaire débridée qui se
terminera comme elle doit se terminer
c'est à dire mal max les banques
centrales sont les seuls responsables
selon vous je suis d'accord avec olivier
pour dire que la crise remonte aux
années 2000 lorsque les banques
centrales étaient très actives pour ce
qui est de l'impression d'argent
ça remonte encore a plutôt cela fait
partie de ce modèle néolibéral qui
échoue de manière catastrophique
tous ces problèmes sont liés aux banques
centrales et à l'impression d'argent
cela cause deux problèmes majeurs numéro
1 des mauvais investissements par
exemple les banques qui auraient dû
faire faillite et être remplacées par de
nouvelles donc fait autorisé à continuer
alors même que techniquement elle fraude
économie de bien des manières
le second problème majeur c'est
l'inflation sur les produits de
l'alimentation ou l'énergie
au delà de l'inflation des prix des
actifs nous voyons une inflation de ce
que nous appelons 'l'indice de créer à
la consommation je me suis pas sûr de
commencer calculé en france mais il
s'agit de l'inflation des prix
quotidien des consommateurs donc serait
devient un problème de plus en plus
grave c'est pourquoi je suis d'accord
avec olivier sur ce point olivier pour
tenter de sauver les meubles de nombreux
pays ont mis en place des plans de
relance et ont débloqué des fonds
du côté européen le plan de relance de
lieux va coûter 750 milliards d'euros
360 sous forme de prêt 390 en
subventions outre atlantique la facture
s'élève à 1900 milliards de dollars et
400 sont consacrés aux aides directes
aux américains 350 aux états et
municipalités locales et des dépenses
qui pèsent sur les dettes comment sortir
de ce quoi qu'il en coûte pour reprendre
l'expression d' emmanuel macron alors il
ya deux choses il faut bien comprendre
que le plan de relance soit enfin soi
disant de relance parce qu'en fait c'est
pas des plans de relance et des plans de
compensation si vous voulez c'est à dire
que on compense du chiffre d'affaires de
société par de la veille donc ça ne
relance rien ça aubert plutôt toutes les
activités qui aura dans le futur ça
c'est la première chose la deuxième
chose c'est que les 750 milliards
je vous rappelle que ils ne sont
toujours pas effectif alors qu'aux états
unis en revanche le plan a été
réellement versé c'est à dire que des
américains ont reçu des chèques
ce qui n'est pas le cas en europe est
nulle part en ordre donc il faut bien
distinguer les deux plans un plan qui a
été annoncé en europe mais qui n'a pas
qui n'est pas rentré dans les faits est
un plan qui a été annoncée qui a été si
vite fait aux états unis ça c'est ces
deux choses maintenant ce genre de plan
si vous voulez malheureusement on n'en
sort pas c'est à dire que vous avez
monsieur bruno le maire qui nous a
annoncé tout sourire que avec la
croissance qui allait repartir
eh bien nous rembourserons les prés de
qui ont été faits pendant le coc vide
or on s'aperçoit que c'est totalement
faux et c'est hot c'est à tel point faut
que ils commencent à se poser la
question de savoir si
ne va pas annuler le remboursement de
certains de ces prêts alors là c'est
encore plus catastrophique mais ça on
sait qu' il ne sait pas compter donc on
n'a pas de surprise là dessus mais si on
va marquer une courte pause et on
revient dans un instant bienvenue dans
ces caches si vous nous rejoignez au
sommaire cette semaine la crise du coc
vite 19 comment tout cela va se terminer
et pour en parler nous sommes en liaison
depuis la caroline du nord aux états
unis avec max keiser ancien trader est
journaliste pour rti international maks
juste avant la coupure pub on évoquait
avec olivier à les plans de relance qui
nous disaient que c'étaient plutôt des
plans de compensation et que ces plans
là on n'en sort pas est ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec ça je suis d'accord à 100%
avec olivier il s'agit d'un plan de
compensation les banques impriment de
l'argent pour elle-même nous savons par
exemple aux états unis quand vous
analysez ce que l'on appelle la vitesse
de circulation de la monnaie qui permet
de suivre
combien d'argent est en circulation et
la vitesse et 2 0 pk car cet argent
imprimé par les banques centrales aient
gardé par les banques et c'est un
système de compensation c'est tout à
fait ça ce n'est pas un système de
croissance qu'on ne peut pas créer de la
croissance en imprimant des billets
comme par magie
ce que vous créez ce sont des problèmes
sociaux et nous avons des troubles
sociaux dans le monde entier en france
aux états unis et dans les pays du monde
à cause de cette idée fausse et que l'on
peut créer de la croissance entraînant
finalement que la fausse monnaie
c'est une terrible erreur diriger tout
droit vers un nouveau bretton woods ont
une remise 1-0 mondiale
mais le système est irrémédiablement
cassé olivier l'ampleur de la crise de
jeu
aura-t-elle des conséquences plus graves
que celles de 2008 sur le long terme
selon vous ou alors est-ce que le fait
que les banques et le système financier
ne soit pas de base à l'origine de ce
choc soit au contraire un petit peu plus
rassurant non le alors il faut bien
comprendre que les banques aujourd'hui
en tout cas les les principales banques
européennes vous l'avez vu il ya
quelques il ya quelques jours à propos
de crédit suisse qui en quelques en
quelques heures a perdu plus de 5
milliards et apparemment il a une
position 20 milliards dans archers
gosses donc la perte pourrait être
encore supérieur
vous êtes on a cru et beaucoup ont cru
que après 2008 les banques auraient pris
certaines leçons et aurait fait en sorte
de ne pas se retrouver dans la même
situation qu'elle s'était trouvé en 2008
or pas du tout aujourd'hui elles sont
exactement dans la même situation
voire pire pourquoi parce qu'en plus
elle se pense à l'abri parce que on a
vaguement remonter le niveau des fonds
propres et qu'elles se disent ça y est
on est on est safe
c'est pas vrai du tout on est dans des
dents dans quasiment les mêmes effets de
levier que ce que vous connaissiez en
vous êtes avec des montants qui sont
gigantesques sur dd sur des des produits
qui sont toujours aussi opaque
les swaps extra qui sont toujours aussi
opaque que il l'était en 2007 et donc
vous avez un risque majeur sur le
système bancaire
en plus de ça vous aviez des bêtes
qu'ils étaient des dettes pourries dans
le système bancaire notamment par
exemple dans le système bancaire italien
avant le col vide vous pensez bien que
ça ça ça ne s'arrangera pas avec le co
vide puisque vous allez avoir tout un
tas d'entreprises qui ne pourront jamais
rembourser leurs emprunts
parce que non n'ayant pas assez
d'activités pour le faire donc vous
aurez très probablement des problèmes
dans l'est dans les banques
et c'est loin d'être fini alors là
c'était 5 milliards c'est maîtrisable on
le crédit suisse
la prochaine fois ça sera peut-être 50
voire 500 et à ce moment là on aura un
vrai problème
mexes du côté à des états unis sur
l'avenir des états unis est ce que
l'arrivée de bail donne peut changer
quelque chose
joe biden fait partie de ces gens aux
états et à washington dc participé à la
création de cette crise revenez 10 15
ans 20 ans en arrière c'est un lobbyiste
de l'industrie des cartes de crédit il a
été pendant de nombreuses décennies
carrière quand il faisait partie de
l'administration barack obama qui fait
partie du groupe clinton à washington
ils ont abrogé déleste eagle par exemple
ils ont présenté la loi sur la
modernisation des contrats à terme sur
les produits de base
débarrassé de beaucoup de règlements qui
contrôlait les marchés et ont ouvert la
voie aux opérations frauduleuses pour
être tout à fait honnête de boxe il est
juste de dire qu'en 2008 les banques au
lieu d'être puni pour avoir commis des
actes illicites
elles ont été renflouées ainsi aux états
unis à cette époque
eric holder qui était procureur général
pour barack obama est arrivé avec une
doctrine
les banques sont au dessus des lois
aujourd'hui aux états unis les banques
sont intouchables et unia hall cru les
réglementations pour elle on n'applique
pas les lois aux banques
la situation est similaire en europe et
notamment au royaume
la fraude bancaire et probablement au
niveau sans doute le plus élevé du monde
ban est cependant il faut retenir que
les banques ne sont pas régulés il n'y a
pas d'application des réglementations
ils peuvent imprimer de l'argent par
milliards de milliards sans aucun
contrôle
ils sont a cause profonde de nombreux
problèmes et la crise du coc vide a
simplement révélé à quel point le
système était fragile en effet on peut
penser que la prochaine grande crise
bancaire que ce soit en europe ou aux
états unis sera bien pire que celle
qu'on avait en 2008
car la solution de 2008 a été simplement
de laisser les banques s'accroître et
fraude est davantage et c'est pourquoi
nous en sommes là aujourd'hui
max pour revenir sur les politiques des
banques centrales est ce que ces
politiques ne risque pas à terme de
faciliter l émergence de nouveaux à
criquetot actif on pense aux obliques
comme par exemple mais il y en a
d'autres
les banques centrales sont effrayés
parce qu'avec bitcoin pu échanger de
l'argent via des serveurs pair à pair et
vous n'avez besoin d'aucune bang bang
également le bitcoin à une politique
monétaire un peu gris et crypté et codé
en termes d'émissions de bitcoin par
jour par année elle est meilleure que
n'importe quelle politique de banque
centrale monétaire et donc les banques
centrales font face à une crise
existentielle quand elles lancent leur
propre devise une devise numérique mais
sera inefficace pour stopper les
personnes car une crypto monnaie d'une
banque centrale est par définition
centralisée
et ne pourrait jamais concurrencer une
guide coyne il est centralisé ce sont
deux systèmes très différents il ne
s'agirait que de réinventer la monnaie
fiduciaire fait si la banque de france
la banque centrale européenne développe
les crypto monnaie ce serait une
reproduction des fiduciaires numérique
patane telle journée il faut également
dire que la plupart des devises en
europe et dans les merdes à l'heure
actuelle ceux déjà des devises numérique
donc il n'y a rien de nouveau
les banques centrales utilisent de
l'argent numérique depuis maintenant des
décennies elles ne représentent pas une
menace pour le bitcoin animaux est une
réelle menace pour les banques centrales
christine lagarde elle-même asie
récemment que bitcoin et glace soupape
de sécurité
elle a tout à fait raison avec le
bitcoin elle peut échapper à la tyrannie
les banques centrales et ces dernières
ne peuvent rien y faire saintes shopping
center par olivier vous êtes d'accord
avec çà me bitcoin une menace pour les
banques centrales
en fait ce mois je crois que c'est pas
une menace pour la banque centrale c'est
le la vraie menace sur la banque
centrale s'est elle même c'est à dire
que c'est ce qu'elles font depuis depuis
des années à régler tous les problèmes
ou enfin en tout cas faire semblant de
régler tous les problèmes en imprimant
de l'argent c'est pas une manière de de
régler les problèmes comme le disait max
tout à l'heure où il disait si vous
créez des billets comme sa part par
milliers de milliards
vous ne
ne créez pas de l'activité vous ne créez
pas l'économie on dit souvent si il
suffisait de créer delà de la monnaie
pour enrichir un pays le zimbabwe serait
le pays plus riches du monde parce qu'il
en a créé il en a bon vous auriez
derrière le japon qui serait le pays
plus riches du monde puisque il n'arrête
pas ils en sont au 14e quantitative
easing donc ils ont de la marge
on est loin derrière donc on sait que ça
ne fonctionne pas or malheureusement
elles ne font que ça et c'est leur seule
et unique réponse à tous les problèmes
il ya un problème de dette on remet de
la dette il ya un problème de denon
circulation de monnaie
eh ben on en met encore un peu plus mais
comme l'a dit max aussi tout à l'heure
la vitesse de circulation est zéro tant
qu'elle est zéro je vous rappelle que la
la formule pour faire de l'inflation
c'est la masse monétaire mais c'est
aussi la vitesse
or si vous avez quelque chose qui est
multiplié par 0 ça donne 0 et donc
donc voilà donc vous n'aurez pas de
création d'activité parce que vous créer
de la monnaie est donc chaque échange
que vous avez dans l'économie réelle
doit se faire avec de la monnaie en
intermédiaires mais c'est pas parce que
vous allez rajouter et rajouter sans
arrêt de la monnaie peut vous aurez une
augmentation de l'activité
donc c'est qu'elle c'est une politique
qui ne sert à rien sauf à détruire les
fondamentaux de l'économie et donc on
peut se demander si on n'est pas plutôt
sur une une feinte de modèles une fin de
civilisation occidentale
plutôt que sur une crise économique ou
une crise sanitaire qui n'est qu'un
épiphénomène à mon avis sur dans l'ordre
des choses depuis 25 ans mac sa dernière
question avant de se quitter olivier
évoqué une feinte de modèles comment
selon vous tout cela va se terminer à la
fin
ce sera la disparition des banques
centrales olivier souligne que les
banques centrales sont leurs propres
ennemis et c'est tout à fait vrai avec
ou sans le bitcoin les banques centrales
s'autodétruisent car l'impression
d'argent les mène à la mort des eaux ce
serait comme si vous donnez un chien des
quantités illimitées de nourriture
le chien va manger jusqu'à en mourir
c'est la même chose avec les banques
centrales personne ne les arrête trait à
la bonne nouvelle c'est l'existence du
bitcoin le guide connu sera un moyen
pour les gens de survivre dans ce
contexte où les banques centrales
s'effondre la monnaie fiduciaire ces
fonds la banque centrale européenne est
très faible
elle pourrait s'effondrer la zone euro
pourraient également s'effondrer parce
que l'allemagne je pense veulent quitter
la zone euro
je pense qu'il veut aussi quitter l'otan
donc cela va créer une crise
géopolitique majeur et je pense qu'avec
le bitcoin vous avez un moyen de
survivre
un moyen pour conserver son niveau de
richesse
malgré une crise existentielle majeur et
mondial max keiser merci beaucoup
d'avoir été parmi nous dans cette
émission je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien trader et animateur de l'émission
kaiser report sur rt internationale
merci encore olivier n'ont pas de
questions cacher
question des var olivier cette
problématique de pénurie de matières
premières ne rejoint t'elle pas votre
émission à précédente sur la
démondialisation
si on produisait plus en france on
aurait moins besoin de la chine qui
favorise son marché intérieur au lieu
d'exporter
on m'a répondu dans l'émission donc je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous et
va merci au lit merci olivier c'est la
fin de cette émission
merci de votre fidélité fidélité pardon
je vais la faire ouais ouais je
m'attendais pas à ça merci olivier c'est
la fin de cette émission merci de votre
fidélité rendez vous sur rt france point
tv pour retrouver toutes les émissions
de ces cas on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
et ensuite avec vous vouliez vous avait
prévenu qu'il y aurait deux méchants on
a eu deux méchants